kartoffeln wachsen unter der erde aber
was ist wenn wir unseren boden gerne
schon möchten und nicht um graben was
aus den verschiedensten gründen ja super
sinnvoll ist kann man dann gar keine
kartoffeln anbauen
doch ich habe da am anfang als ich
angefangen habe ohne umgraben zu werten
ein super viele fragezeichen gehabt und
super viel experimentiert und hin und
her probiert bis wir die techniken
herausgefunden haben die wir jetzt
nutzen um unsere kartoffeln komplett
ohne umgraben anzubauen und trotzdem
noch einen guten ertrag zu bekommen
kartoffeln sind für uns super super
wichtig weil wir eben versuchen
möglichst viel von dem was wir essen als
familie selbst anzubauen gleichzeitig
ist es mir aber auch total wichtig dass
wir nicht nur für uns gärtnern sondern
auch für die ganzen lebewesen die hier
in diesem garten zu hause sind zum
beispiel auch für das bodenleben und
deswegen haben wir uns entschieden dass
wir unsere bete nicht umgegraben
das ist auch für uns super praktisch
weil unsere beete dadurch quasi
unkrautfrei bleiben und der boden wenn
er nicht umgegraben wird wasser viel
besser speichern kann so dass wir viel
weniger gießen müssen und am ende des
videos zeige ich euch noch eine zweite
technik mit der ihr komplett neue beete
mit kartoffeln anlegen könnt das heißt
ihr bekommt ein komplett neues b dass
ihr ganz ohne umgraben und ohne viel
aufwand angelegt habt und obendrauf
kommt auch noch die kartoffelernte
darüber sprechen wir also später jetzt
reden wir erst mal über den normalen
anbau wenn man schon ein bild hat und
kartoffeln ohne umgraben anbauen möchte
meine erste idee war dass sich die
kartoffeln einfach auf den boden
drauflegen
das heißt in ein fertiges bild einfach
auf den boden drauf und dann nur noch
milch oben drauf packen das problem
dabei war aber dass durch jede form von
milch so viel licht durch gekommen ist
dass die kartoffeln ganz schnell grün
geworden sind wenn kartoffeln licht
ausgesetzt sind dann entwickelt sich so
lanin dann werden die kartoffeln grünen
werden sie giftig dass es ein fraß
schutzmechanismus damit die kartoffeln
sich gegen fraßfeinde schützen können
und damit sind die kartoffeln für uns
relativ unbrauchbar
man kann sie dann nur noch als salat
kartoffeln verwenden so funktioniert das
also schon mal nicht und es ist auch
gleich ein zweites problem aufgetaucht
die ernte war wirklich nicht gut und das
ist auch eigentlich logisch weil die
kartoffeln brauchen ja irgendwie
schade um sich drum rum aus der sie
nährstoffe entnehmen können so dass sie
überhaupt groß und dick werden können
und viele knollen bilden können das war
also relativ frustrierend weil wir sehr
viele sack kartoffeln verloren haben und
dann wieder unsere kartoffeln aus dem
laden kaufen mussten weil sie quasi
keine verwertbare ernte hatten das waren
also zwei riesen große fragezeichen in
meinem kopf einmal wie kriege ich jetzt
hin dass die kartoffel nicht grün werden
und dann wie kriege ich sehen dass die
ernte einigermaßen okay ist so dass du
nicht quasi mehrzad kartoffeln aus
pflanzen letztendlich an erntereif
bekommst wäre das dann alles überhaupt
keinen sinn ergibt sich aber an den
punkten so ein bisschen frustriert weil
ich bin ein sehr starker verfechter des
gärtnerns ohne umgraben und das hilft
uns auf so vielen ebenen so arg weiter
unser gemüse ohne viel arbeit quasi
komplett selber anzubauen aber bei den
kartoffeln da waren echt viele viele
große fragezeichen im kopf da war also
das eingeständnis dass wir um ein
bisschen graben beim kartoffelanbau auch
im nautic garten nicht drum herum kommen
und ich erspare ich jetzt die 50 andere
experimente die ich auch noch gemacht
habe und zeige euch wie es richtig
funktioniert
die kartoffeln brauchen ein bisschen
erde um sich drum rum das muss gar nicht
mal unbedingt viel sein und was sich bei
uns am meisten bewährt hat ist dass wir
die kartoffeln erst mal relativ normal
pflanzen das heißt wir machen entweder
mit der schaufel einen kleinen schlitz
in die erde
der ungefähr zehn zentimeter tief ist
und legen da die kartoffel ab und
verteilen die erde wieder um sie herum
so dass wir den boden möglichst wenig
bewegen oder wir ziehen sogar eine
furche die zehn zentimeter tief ist dass
es immer noch viel besser für den boden
als wenn man ihn wirklich umgraben würde
und legen da unsere kartoffeln ab ich
gebe beim pflanzen immer noch ein ganz
paar hornspäne vielleicht so ein
teelöffel pro pflanzkartoffel mit dem
pflanzloch das hilft den kartoffeln dann
dass sie auch genug nährstoffe haben
auch wenn wir sie gar nicht so doll mit
erde bedecken und die eigentliche
erdbewegung die kommt im traditionellen
kartoffelanbau erst nach dem pflanzen
nämlich wenn man häufig damit man die
kartoffel knollen vor licht schützt und
damit die pflanzen mehr knollen
ausbilden können und nach allen
experimenten die ich gemacht habe ist
dass häufeln immer noch die wirksamste
methode um die kartoffeln vor licht zu
schützen und zu
verhindern dass sie grün werden wir
ziehen also sobald die kartoffel triebe
ungefähr 15 zentimeter aus der erde
schauen die erde die um die kartoffeln
herum liegt zwischen den reihen neben
den rein auf die reihen sodass wir die
pflanzen wieder quasi komplett mit erde
bedecken so dass sie vielleicht noch ein
kleines bisschen rausschauen
das ist das ganz normale häufeln und das
machen wir ein bis maximal zwei mal
einfach damit die kartoffeln selbst erst
mal von der erdschicht bedeckt sind
wo kaum licht durch kommt weil die
meisten materialien die wir später auf
dem beet aus bringen sind so blass die
die kartoffeln nicht effektiv vor licht
schützen können aber nach dem was wir
ausprobiert haben
reichen diese ein bis zweimal häufeln
völlig aus um das ergebnis zu bekommen
dass man beim normalen umgraben auch
bekommt und gleichzeitig so wenig erde
wie möglich zu bewegen
und wenn ihr meinen kanal schon länger
verfolgt dann wisst ihr dass wir unsere
nicht um grabe beete mit kompost anlegen
das heißt wir haben ungefähr 10 bis 15
cm kompost der oben auf dem mutterboden
auflegt und unten in den mutterboden da
sind die ganzen unkrautsamen da ist
quasi ein unerschöpfliches potenzial an
unkrautsamen so dass wir immer
verhindern wollen dass der mutterboden
nach oben kommt der kompressor immer
oben bleiben und mit dieser minimalen
bodenbearbeitung die wir jetzt in
unserem kompromiss no dig kartoffelanbau
haben da so haben wir eben dafür dass
diese schichtung immer noch intakt
bleibt weil wir den boden so wenig wie
möglich bewegen wenn ihr jetzt völlig
neu hier seid ein bisschen auf dem
schlauch steht was das für komische
kompost beete sind dann sage ich euch
gerne noch mal den link zu meinem
gemüsegarten boot camp in die video
beschreibung unten rein da könnt ihr
euch kostenlos für anmelden und wenn sie
ihnen schritt für schritt anleitung wie
wir diese beete anlegen und nachdem wir
die pflanzen dann ein bis zweimal
geheuchelt haben lassen wir das seien
dann bewegen wir die erde nicht mehr und
packen nur noch ganz viel mut ich immer
wieder auf die pflanzen darauf dass
heißt immer wenn die um 15 zentimeter
oben rausschauen
dann kommt wieder mulch obendrauf dafür
kann man ganz unterschiedliche
materialien verwenden die alle ihre vor
und nachteile haben man kann zum
beispiel mit altem heu oder stroh
münchen man kann laut verbänden oder den
rasenschnitt wenn man gerade den rasen
gemäht hat fällt er ja sowieso an
wir wollen am allerliebsten mit
holzhackschnitzeln bei
die auch noch gegen schnecken wirken
alle anderen mulch materialien sind sehr
feucht und gemütlich für schnecken so
dass die sich da ganz gerne breit machen
das ist der große nachteil von mulch
aber wenn man holzhackschnitzel
verwendet dann schafft man er einstecken
und freundliches klima weil die sind ja
total scharf kundig und die schnecken
sind sehr empfindlich und die mögen da
überhaupt nicht gerne drüber griechen
wenn ihr nicht genug eigene hexe habt
dann ruft einfach mal bei baumpflege
betrieben an da bekommt man oft welche
die häckseln ja ständig irgendwelche
bäume und sind manchmal auch ganz froh
wenn sie dann los werden können sprechen
wir über den pflanzabstand das ist auch
so eine sache
normalerweise wird empfohlen dass man
kartoffel mit einem abstand von 35 x 70
bis 80 zentimetern pflanzt das ist
ziemlich viel platz pro pflanze
wir machen das ziemlich anders und das
haben vielleicht schon einige von euch
in dem einen oder anderen clip gesehen
dass wir unsere kartoffeln sehr sehr
dicht pflanzen
das liegt daran dass wir sehr gute
erfahrungen damit gemacht haben was wie
ich glaube daran liegt dass wir mit
kompost gärtnern und die beete einfach
sehr sehr fruchtbar sind so dass wir
auch mit einem kleineren pflanzabstand
immer noch einen sehr guten ertrag haben
bzw
der ertrag bei uns sogar noch besser ist
wenn wir den kleineren pflanzabstand
wählen
ich habe kartoffeln schon 60 x 20 cm
dicht gepflanzt das ist schon um einiges
dichter als es normalerweise empfohlen
wird aber ich tue mich so ein bisschen
schwer damit das jetzt zu
verallgemeinern weil das nichts ist was
wir schon super lange so ausprobieren
also ich habe würde ich jetzt mal sagen
die letzten drei jahre damit
herumexperimentiert aber ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob das nur allgemein gültig
und vorbei ist ich würde euch vielleicht
ein kompromiss pflanzabstand empfehlen
von 60 mal 30 zentimetern
damit fahre auf jeden fall nicht ganz
verkehrt es geht ein bisschen in die
richtung von meiner erfahrungen aber ich
bin mir da eben selber noch gar nicht so
sicher was der beste abstand ist und
werden die nächsten jahren immer weiter
experimentieren und euch dann sobald ich
ein ergebnis habe wo ich auch voll
dahinter stehen kann und weiß das hat
hand und fuß dann würde ich das auch mit
euch teilen aber bis dahin würde ich mal
eher auf 60 mal 30 zentimeter gehen wenn
ihre
kartoffeln jetzt pflanzen volt kommt
unsere letzte große hürde die ernte
steht an wie sein wir unsere kartoffeln
denn jetzt aus dem boden raus kriegen
ohne den umzug haben
das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so das
problem weil der boden dadurch dass wir
gehofft haben dass wir ohne umgraben
gärtnern viel mit kompost arbeiten super
locker ist das heißt wir lockern den
boden um die kartoffelpflanzen herum
erst mal vorsichtig mit einer grabegabel
auf natürlich ohne ihn zu wenden das
heißt einfach nur ein stechen ein
bisschen hin und her bewegen
dadurch ist die erde einfach von
vornherein schon super locker und wir
haben es bei der ernte eigentlich gar
nicht mehr so schwer
ich habe den mund bei seite der macht
den größten teil der masse aus die auf
den kartoffeln drauf ist und dann ist
gar nicht mehr so viel erde auf den
pflanzen drauf weil wir ja nur ein bis
zweimal geheuchelt haben und die ist
meist auch ziemlich locker noch vom
häufeln die schiebt man dann einfach ein
bisschen beiseite und dann sieht man
schon seine dicken knollen das heißt wir
müssen gar nicht graben wir können die
meistens sogar einfach mit dem bloßen
händen ganz gut einfach absammeln auf
dem boden
die sind oft auch viel sauberer als wenn
man die normal mit umgraben anbauen
würde und wir haben trotzdem noch einen
super ertrag und dadurch dass wir nicht
umgraben bleibt ihr die natürliche boden
schichtung aufrechterhalten das heißt
der boden hat noch richtig struktur und
das verleiht ihm eine super kraft
nämlich kann der boden dann viel besser
wasser speichern und wir gießen unsere
kartoffeln überhaupt nicht und bauen
unsere kartoffeln also ohne bewässerung
auch in den heißen sommern die gerade
hinter uns liegen immer noch sehr
erfolgreich komplett ohne umgraben an
kartoffel haben auch eine super power
und zwar unterdrücken die richtig gut
jegliche form von gras und unkraut die
um sie herum wächst und das können wir
uns zunutze machen wenn wir neue beete
anlegen wollen
ihr habt also einen ort an dem ihr
unbedingt ein neues beet braucht man
kann ja auch nie genug fläche haben und
ich habe gestern meinen b ziemlich
spontan angelegt das heißt ich hatte
leider keine rasenkante zur hand wenn
ihr das macht dann würde ich euch aber
empfehlen rundherum da wo ihr euer
kartoffeln anbauen wollt oder anlegen
voltaire ist meine rasenkante
einzugraben
das meiste unkraut was man so hart wenn
man ohne umgraben gärtnert das ist was
von außen in die beete rein wachsen will
und wenn der rasenkante kann man das
richtig gut abblocken so dass man wie so
eine kleine festung burgmauer um
sämtliche trüben hat und die unkräuter
so nicht von außen ins beet wachsen das
erleichtert einem das leben wirklich
ungemein und ich kann aus erfahrung
sagen das ist super ärgerlich ist wenn
man eine rasenkante aus plastik
verwendet weil die nach zwei jahren
spätestens komplett zersplittert ist und
die plastikteile sich überall im garten
verteilen also wenn jene rasenkante
benutzen wollt dann auf jeden fall einer
aus metall nehmen auch wenn die teurer
sind aber ihr werdet an den plastikding
an keine freude haben glauben wir und
jetzt packen wir richtig viel stroh auf
das beet drauf am besten natürlich bio
stroh verwenden wenn ihr biologisch
gärtnern möchte damit ihr euch nicht die
ganze spritzmittel in den garten holt
wir sprechen da jetzt von ungefähr 40
zentimeter dick stroh dass ihr schön
oben auf eurem geht aus bringen und wenn
das so richtig schön gemütlich aussieht
dann können wir uns unsere
pflanzkartoffeln schnappen und dann
machen wir mit einem anderen
pflanzabstand als bei den kompost beten
wir nehmen jetzt einem weiteren
pflanzabstand von ungefähr
ja ich habe jetzt so 50 mal 50 bis 60 x
60 cm genommen habt ihr jeweils ein loch
für die pflanzkartoffel in das stroh bis
ihr das gras sieht dann legt er die
kartoffel da rein und dann kommt
obendrauf eine gute suppe kompost ich
habe diese methode habe ich euch jetzt
hält auch schon ausprobiert ohne den
kompost und das reicht den kartoffeln
einfach nicht der kompass schützt die
davor dass ihr grün werden wir müssen
sie dann später auch nicht häufig weil
wir relativ viel gut relativ dicke
schicht kompost jetzt oben drauf packen
die kartoffeln wachsen dadurch und haben
trotzdem genug erde um sich herum dass
ihr trotzdem noch einen ganz guten
ertrag bekommt das ist nicht so gut wie
wenn ihr die kartoffeln im normalen
schon bestehenden beete anbaut also der
ertrag wird ein bisschen niedriger sein
aber hey dafür bekommt ihr halt auch ein
neues beet kann ich alles auf einmal
ihr könnt noch ein bisschen mehr muss
ich um die kartoffelpflanzen drumrum
verteilen wenn die schon ein bisschen
größer sind also das hilft auf jeden
fall dass sie möglichst nicht grün
werden
aber meine erfahrung nach klappt das
auch wunderbar wenn man das bild jetzt
einfach so sich selbst überlässt und
dann erst im spätsommer oder herbst zur
ernte anrückt und wenn die kartoffeln
geerntet sind dann könnt ihr gleich das
nächste gemüse für den winter einsehen
ich bin der meinung dass sich jeder der
gemüse anbaut auch mit dem thema boden
auseinandersetzen sollte weil das so so
wichtig ist dass der boden fruchtbar und
lebendig ist und deswegen schaue gerne
in dem video da drüben vorbei weil da
tauchen wir noch viel tiefer in das
thema gärtnern ohne umgraben 1
ansonsten gehe raus macht die welt ein
bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns am
samstag wieder für ein neues video und
tschüss